good evening everyone
thank you for coming and i guess i want
to welcome myself to this beautiful
auditorium here in north conway thank
you for having us here
um this is quite lovely what a lovely
high school you have up here and uh we
all were
happy to be up here
so the highway projects are the same all
over the state isn't that nice to know
all right i apologize to people here and
listening that we are starting a few
minutes late as i said there was a
little traffic and we wanted to make
sure
all members of the
redistricting committees of the house
and senate of the new hampshire general
court were here that we knew were coming
so having said that um i would this is
business of your general court for the
state of new hampshire and i would like
to begin tonight by saying the pledge of
allegiance so if you would join me in
standing there is the flag over here
[Music]
one nation under god indivisible with
liberty and justice
[Music]
as
you might know this session is being
video and audio recording and
subsequently placed online and made
publicly available
house or senate um not all members are
present here tonight
staff of the general court has worked to
secure this meeting for those who are
watching we are in carroll county at the
kennedy high school
and i and committee are certainly
grateful to the staff that arranged this
in the organizations that um control the
use of this facility and thank you for
the microphone
it's really terrific
as i said this is a joint meeting of the
house
and the senate committees on
redistricting
we have both committee members so we're
actually really conducting two meetings
at once and you didn't think your
government was sufficient here we
are to introduce the senate and to
officially open the senate video i'm
going to turn to my rights senator gray
well thank you very much i am
james gray i am the chair of the
senate special
committee on redistricting i'm also the
chair of the election law committee
before i pass the mic
i do want to remind the audience that
senate rules don't allow cheering booing
clapping if you want to express your
opinion get up use the microphone and
talk to us
okay and with that i will pass my money
thank you
um
good evening everyone my name
is district 21 on the seacoast which is
portsmouth durham new market and the
surrounding towns and my
family is joining us here tonight so
just be nice to us
thank you my name is barbara griffin i'm
a representative from boston and i'm
going to start by turning over to the
representative
[Music]
hi i'm bob i'm a representative from
windsor new hampshire i'm
[Music]
good evening my name is marcus smith i
represent durham and manbury in the
house i serve on the judiciary committee
and on this
special committee on redistricting
my name is paul bergeron i represent
national war 2 and in addition to this
committee i spurred on the house
election
thank you uh
thank you for coming and thank you for
having us here it's beautiful
my name is lucy weber i represent
cheshire district one which is local
westmoreland chesterfield sales which is
the
privacy you know southwest and still be
in new hampshire so it was
[Music]
human services and elderly
i'm sorry i have a long day
thank you representative
as this meeting is being watched online
i want to take this opportunity to speak
to the overall process you can be
watching this online by going to the
general court website and clicking on
the special committee on redistricting
and the access to the live video screen
is available there
or on the general court page and to
information on the redistricting process
for the house of representatives can be
found on the general court website and
once they reselect the house of
representatives and then go to the
committee stated committee site where
the special committee on redistricting
has a link
when you get to the special
committee on redistricting page there's
a link that allows you to email all
committee members
also has a web page
there is also something on the page for
a meeting mix recordings um information
that the committee has been considering
and there's also a link there for people
to submit comments and maps online so we
can take a look at what members of the
public line
and of course we're here for the public
input in regards to what you might want
to see for nas
we're here for redistricting which is a
process that occurs throughout the
country every 10 years after the federal
census is completed and that population
that is used to create districts for
representatives at all levels of
government here in new hampshire our
constitution says the responsibility for
the creation of those districts is that
of the legislature the districts to be
redrawn in new hampshire will be the
congressional
executive council
state senate and state representatives
there's also redistricting for county
commissioners and the state party
convention
there were some handouts out outside
with some information for you and that
has some more detail on carroll county
and from the representative health side
it's it's helpful for us to hear what
you think might be important or might
what works or doesn't work for you here
in the county
there were sign sheets and there should
be one out front for you to sign up if
you'd like to speak
it just helps us organize the meeting a
little more and we have a microphone up
here for you to speak to and since we're
recording
[Music]
and so with that
we are here to receive comments that you
might have i know some of you were able
to see want some information that
a group here in new hampshire presented
or is presenting in regards to map
redrawing and with that i'm just going
to go over the border
and representative
has
[Music]
well we all know the goal of
redistricting
is to ensure equal representation of
people in each district
when that population shifts but
obviously we know for centuries
to govern in 1812
that redistricting has been a vehicle
for partisan gerrymandering in order to
strengthen the political grip of the
body of power at any other moment
of democracy
but use computer power and big data has
allowed ever more powerful journeys
so we all know the eagles are journey
language and increases complete
investment history it leads to increased
political extremism enemies the widening
of our political divide
and that partisan appearance erodes
people's faith in the political process
constitutionally the legislature has to
prove that no matter what method is used
but the process can be done in a way
some of the gerrymandering those of you
want election law committee from the
house
i know that i've had a long interest in
this and over my five years i've
sponsored bills to promote their
redistricting
politics
on
[Music]
using the efficiency as developed by
stephanopoulos
and then subsequent outlier analysis as
a tool to measure the process
of showing the partisans
and i used to use those purposefully
back in 2017
metrics in that process as well
to be able to confirm that what they
came up with was a fairly distributed
process
again each of these bills is processed
only the final approval by the
legislative comply with the constitution
and actually
became working on that i was co-authored
with
congratulations for that plan in 2016
democratic party platform that opposed
on a partisan basis so the bottom line
is
what you're going through now i really
urge you to use the principles of an
inclusive and transparent process that
respects communities of interest and
compactness
and you know i would kind of heard you
would submit this plan as it develops to
testing using some of these methods
such as the efficiency gap with hot wire
analysis or other techniques that ended
up
to assess and reinforcing the
[Music]
because if such metrics demonstrate only
the low probability of gerrymandering
and the match you develop
you're going to do a lot to restore the
faith of the voters in our political
process
and you'll save off any of the usual
lawsuits you face every 10 years
if they instead demonstrate your high
level of hearing then you know they're
trying to be indefensible
bottom line
is for the redistricting maps to be
responsive to the role of people
so they can elect whom they wish
because it's time to let the voters keep
their candidates
rather than attendance to their voters
thank you very much
thank you
next week
[Music]
i want to begin by thanking you all for
coming especially since the drive was so
slow today i really appreciate you
all the hard work you've invested in
this whole process
and it's a huge responsibility your work
will impact all of us in the years ahead
this past year people in 74 towns and
municipalities around the state
voted to support the new hampshire
resolution for non-partisan fair
registered gain
clearly the public desires a fair open
and impartial redistricting process
your special commission has taken a good
first step by
scheduling the listening sessions like
you're having tonight
in each county
however the community must follow up
these listening sessions with four
additional actions
first the special redistricting
committee should immediately disclose
the criteria they are using to create
the new voting districts
second
once the maps are drawn by the special
committee they need to be made available
to the public
each citizen deserves an opportunity to
see the maps
study the maps and then comment on the
maps
therefore another hearing is imperative
further the second term needs to provide
an option for citizens to participate
remotely
i have spoken with many people over the
course of these last few weeks who
cannot attend in-person meetings due to
probing concerns or other health issues
many of them care deeply about your
district and wanted to be here tonight
they deserve a chance to both hear
information and give testimony directly
to this
committee
remote access would provide them with
this opportunity
finally i want to urge you to
incorporate the population data with
communities of interest data
this spring nonpartisan groups such as
the league of women voters and open
democracy gathered people from around
the state from participating the
mapathon citizen mapping project
i was one of the citizens who
participated in this project by filling
out information about the town that i
live in hamler
the data was then meticulously compiled
and mapped strong using both population
numbers and communities of interest data
i've looked at these maps and believe
they present fair non-partisan and
balanced solutions to redistricting
please consider using these maps when
making decisions and thank you again for
all your hard work
thank you
also signed up is gabrielle watson
evening i want to also thank you very
much for the opportunity to participate
in
a crucial process to share
our ideas about what it is going to take
to get fair and
for leaderships for the sake of new
hampshire i'm gabrielle watson i'm from
the town of tamworth
um
where a rural community likes a rural
community that looks north to the mexico
and
we're connected to a number of the
communities around us through
common interests like farmers markets
and fairs
and
activities that come in
i'm very worried
that our country and our communities are
being divided and stood apart
and so this process is crucial to help
us assure that we have non-partisan and
fair districts that everybody can trust
and have confidence in
to secure our sense of confidence in our
democracy in general
what i would like to see and what i
think this means is that we need to
understand the criteria that you're
using
and to have a clear and transparent
process
to understand how you're drawing the
maps and have an opportunity
to see them
i think it's important to keep our
school districts together and public
health regions together these are some
of the communities of interest
that we identified during this process
of citizen-led and citizen-oriented
mapping
um that ellen was just describing
and keeping the districts compact so
that the people who live and are
represented by
their representatives
share cultural resources share interests
in common can know each other and live
close to each other so they go to the
same medical facilities
um all of this helps us collaborate
around regional initiatives like montana
is struggling with how
[Music]
um
so those sprawling you know districts
that go from one side of the state to
the other obviously
communities in the far ends of those
districts have nothing in common with
each other other than having a shared
right center who may not be listening to
all of the members of your district
people
um very specifically in tamworth
we share a lot of bonds with the
community of sandwich and so that's
that's an interest that i would like to
express
i know it's complicated because you're
needing to follow a lot of
rules about numbers and um
you know compactness and
being
contiguous with other communities but
that's one thing that for us in
particular professorship so much between
our two communities and also with
madison
those are some that's one thing in
particular i'm interested in and then
finally the last thing that i wanted to
speak to today is
is really the importance that people
need to have a chance to have a safe and
fair
it's wonderful to have a listening
session and to listen ahead of time
before you develop the maps
but we need to see those maps that we
develop and be able to respond
that might make them
more representative and more
responsive to the interests that we
share as communities
um
so while the listening session is great
and
despite not having a zoom which you
would think after 18 months you would
have been able to figure out how to have
some participation in a public
consultation process but um
um i do think that we need to know or i
guess the question that i have is when
will we see the draft maps and when will
we see the criteria that you're using to
draw those maps so that we can
understand your thinking behind the maps
um and when um
will you be taking public comments on
those maps and how much time will we
have to make comments on those maps
before they're voted on it seems as
though we would need at least two weeks
before
they're finalized and they're voted on
in order to have any kind of meaningful
input
into the substance of what you've
developed through their hard
work um
so i would like to urge you to commit to
having another round of public
appearance after their acts are released
and before they're voted on
and potentially consider if it's not
feasible to have the zoom interaction in
all of the public
um hearings than to have a standalone
session for all of those people we have
a number of people who are
compromised medically you weren't able
to be here tonight but who've been
participating with us in our preparation
for
thinking about what we wanted to say
tonight so i urge you to consider at
least having this participation option
for those people
thank you
again thank you
also signed up to
bring us tonight
[Music]
allowing us to
express our opinions uh
as members of the redistricting board
you must decide who you're going to
listen to
as this
[Music]
in my opinion the balanced approach
will best serve republicans
democrats and undeclared voters
and our state and our democracy
i'm going to provide three stories that
happened approximately during the last
week or so
the first
is an example
among
the republican party and extremists
please do not listen to these folks
and they're ill
when making your convictions
today we all said the pledge of
allegiance to the united states of
america
i hope all of us
and all of you
believe every word of it and are not
just mouthing those words
i bring it up because nine gop members
of the new hampshire
house of representatives recently
postponed a bill
which provides for a quote
that the state peaceably declares
independence
from independence to the united states
and proceeds as a sovereign nation
this is what extremist leading
redistricting brings forth
they are returning
our pledge to one nation under god
story two
the new hampshire executive council with
his cop majority
following the lead of anti-masters
anti-vaccine extremists who
at one point forced the cancellation
unit
that board then later rejected 27
million dollars in federal funding to
help the state by your pilgrimage
they did so even though governor chris
sununu later said our state
coveted response really demands
depends on this money
it's a disservice to all of us
we are elected to serve to anyone
watching
it seemed the executive council caved in
to the screaming law
the extremists
now new hampshire is the only state
in the nation to have declined abundant
and in essence
gave our hard
earned tax moneys a way to support other
states like massachusetts vermont new
york
new jersey
allow them fight probably
this is not very fiscally responsible
and again
some of this was pushed forward by
extremists and that's why i'm pleading
with you not to take that course
story three and there's a message in
there
in multiple also this week
similar anti-vaccine anti-matters groups
demanded via petition that a vote be
held by the school board
the petition demanded to mask the
optional or extracurricular activities
it would reverse the school board's
mandate
however
the good people of very conservative
leading moultonborough
voted to support the school board's mass
standard
more than 350 people voted
and 57 percent of them voted for the
mandate
it's a backlash toward the extreme
and it might be for the republican party
a harbinger of the future
you have a choice
as you may redistricting you will you
can listen to the good people of both
world
by the extremists some of whom would
divide our nation and separate your
nation from it
it could backfire and permanently hurt
the gop
especially if moltenborough is a sign
where rational voters are headed
which is a way of extremist politics i
hope all of you consider
to stay as far away from it as you can
and your balance district
to bring our country back into balance
our state back thanks
thank
you
representatives tonight
[Music]
think everything that i would have said
has been said
um
i'm having trouble understanding exactly
what the criteria is listed somewhere
[Music]
i don't know all of the dynamics that we
use in those maps when i look at them
they look like they have been use to
make it as fair
as possible
and i think fairness is the thing that
needs to be considered
need to be fair to all citizens any
state
not just one party or the other
i think if you look at the numbers
democrats
and republicans are not able with this
awesome lives
in the middle
i would just like to have
good representation of their thoughts
and ideas
in the state house
and washington
the following thing that i would like to
comment on is
when you do publish your
maps your essays
[Music]
probably a lot less confidence
but thank you very much for your time
here tonight and
i appreciate the work you're doing and
that's difficult to make all the members
fit together
and trying to get communities of
interest together
and
keep this state
on a forward path
not on a divisive
[Music]
okay well thank you
i didn't check to see if there was
nobody else
is there anybody else here who would
like to say something specific comments
as to districts right now is
[Music]
come
thank down and it's good to see
several former colleagues before thank
you
um and thanks for the work that you're
doing i know this is difficult and uh
will continue to be until
uh when january february um
but
representative could you please
introduce yourself for the minutes
thank you
something that i haven't paid much
attention to and that
i appreciate that there is information
there that we can
use and maybe not used enough is the
committee website
and so i just want to point out that
uh if i haven't been looking at it i'm
sure that many other people haven't done
it as well i know that there is the
um nonpartisan group i'm working on
developing maps but i just encourage all
of us to use
the uh house website as well and look at
all of the work that uh or all of the
information that is there um and as
representative said my concerns are
essentially the same as those you've
heard transparency
that there is a deadline of november
but i also understand that the deadlines
in the legislature have been and will
continue to be flexible
and it is possible for you
not necessarily to return to every
county
with the maps but to somehow provide a
process where we can see
the work that you do
and
having an
i think it opportunity go a long ways
towards
having
[Music]
trust in the process
um you've heard concerns about having a
virtual meeting we can't do it
but possibly do one i know that it is
the speaker's
designation that there should be no
virtual meetings
and
in terms of communities of interest or
communities of affinity
i live in the little finger at the top
of the counter
it
sticks its finger into pronounce
suggest that our affinity is north to
coast instead of south to the congress
[Music]
most of our guests and
those residents in our town
um are going to bark are going to come
are going to tamworth they're going to
jax
[Music]
relationship between co-ops and grafton
which is a natural
geographic
connection
and
redoes it so that that
geographic connection is to
the northern part of downtown
it's not as
comfortable
uh a relationship i don't think because
sugar hill in those areas have always
been related to
uh littleton and bethlehem in a way
that northern federal council is not so
i would hope that you would appreciate
that uh concern and consider it as you
put your
final maps together
and again thank you very much for your
time and for coming all this way
and going to every county to hear us
and please come back to us with
the possibility of having some kind of
commentary before you finalize your work
thank you
questions
[Music]
about exactly why
heart celebration is in
this town
given the way
the finger
is
maps and other regions don't always make
a lot of sense so that probably means
fun
all right thank you
is there anybody else here that wants to
speak
representative
good evening and
thank you all for being here
[Music]
uh terrell district three
i had been through this process on two
occasions
it served two different uh communities
uh sometimes singling one out and moving
over
i've seen people sit on this committee
to draw these lines and never hold
office again
and they don't hold office again because
they have taken their jobs seriously and
when their lives are drawn not always
benefits the people that are sitting
behind themselves
so i know many of you i know you're
hardworking
and i know your commitment to
our state will be taken
my position at two different uh two
different registries
and i'm looking at third
because i will stand proud and serve
whoever you give me
[Music]
is
um
i
have uh lived in this town for
quite a while i
still sleep in the same bedroom i was
standing on the spot
and uh
as a young democrat growing up
around here and as a young man
i was appalled
at how many republicans there were
around
[Music]
um and i wish for many years
that someone could do something about it
and change that
uh well they did and i think they kind
of overdid it
and as
an older ex-democrat
who was
rather dismayed at his party
former party at the moment
i'm just hoping that you can do
something to reverse the process
[Music]
madison i really have a question more
than a speech
i worked on the census with my husband
and it was a wonderful experience i've
worked on it two previous sessions
and that is i assume the basis for this
process um but maybe a dumb question
where is the information that was
gathered how is it impacting what you're
doing
i'm still getting some of you to come on
down
anybody else
[Music]
excuse me my name is
we've talked about fairness and balance
so
to provide some balance for the
former democratic gentleman who was just
here
but i get on record as saying i'm a
recovering republican
in a way
that drives home the point i want to
make
which is
party affiliation shouldn't have
anything to do with the districting
process
my former party has done and
i think you guys shouldn't give an arm
about whatever
any of your party has done
your focus is simple
a fair balance a reasonable match
uh
i expect it's unlikely that you'll come
up with something that
everybody keeps prays on
but my hope is you'll be able to come up
with something
that most everybody keeps praise on and
that
republican leadership will probably be
unhappy with
democratic leadership although
pretending to be more open and
will secretly be unhappy with it
and daniel
is
[Music]
i
efficiency as a law in terms of the
representatives
and i would submerge it as much as
possible that we would avoid multiple
districts by trying to
divide
either dominant accounts against
[Music]
the population and
therefore
[Music]
just to clarify for us
just so you know there's probably nobody
here to give you a definitive answer on
this let's just hold off the current
maps i believe it is
the over
[Music]
it's it's the deviation from the magic
number which last time was 3
or multiples thereof in
multiple member districts
and as you would likely
realize
the thing that's really tricky is
because we have to keep towns together
and because
every town has to be in a base district
um and because they can't cross county
lines and they certainly can't cross
state lines
uh trying to make the numbers come out
right when almost everybody else in the
country uses census blocks rather than
keeping their house together
is very difficult
and
when you have a floater
on the top of that
when you have one town that's only a
little bit off and one town was very
much off
that then throws that out and
the new hampshire supreme court will
tell us we can't do it that way and
those
those are the considerations that have
to be taken into consideration before
you even get to the communities of
interest piece
which is why it's really difficult in
the house it's much easier to sell it
because thank you representatives
[Music]
is slightly higher
what if anything is
[Music]
is there anybody else
all right well i think i am going to
take this chance to sort of go over a
little bit about what i spoke at the
beginning there's lots of comments about
providing student access if you want to
access that means you can be watching us
on youtube right now as we're speaking
and you will be able to go online to the
general court website and watch this
meeting tomorrow if you didn't have
enough of it tonight because i'm going
to post it usually pretty much first in
the morning
and
you can take a look at it there you can
also take a look at all the other
publication sessions we've had we have
two more
scheduled next week we have hillsborough
and donald county
also on that website to review we have
the laws that govern this we have the
and those criteria have been discussed
at meetings
and agreed upon which are
constitutionally
required
we also have to make certain assumptions
in regards to cities
in regards to populations
when you start to talk 400
representatives and trying to figure out
how you're going to split them up
between 1.3 plus million people it
starts to get pretty
complicated with the numbers and keep in
mind we have to stay within council
boundaries we can't go outside
accounting for your representatives here
in carroll county
so if you go on that website you will be
able to see what we've been talking
about and criteria and again you can
take a look at what maps have been
submitted
um you can view submitted testimony and
it will ask you what bill you want to
look at and the bills are for
the various things i told you about at
the beginning in regards to rediscipline
the senate is one bill the house is
another bill
the congressional districts are another
bill so you can just look at the list
and pick the district you click on it
and then you can see
the submissions
and i'm on it pretty much every day so i
know that there are some maps up there
so you can take a look at those maps and
you can submit
testimony to the committee directly from
that website by going back and forth so
as has been referenced there have been
sort of decisions made about soon
meetings if people want to talk to me
afterwards about it i'm happy to um but
if you are able to participate in the
consumers you can get on the website and
get that information to us and i will
tell you it will get to all committee
members
as i explained not all committee members
are here tonight
but those emails to committee members go
to everyone and that website can be
viewed by everyone so we certainly
encourage you
to use it because we're we're pretty
happy it's up there i'd like to look a
little for you but it's certainly
personal and can get you the information
that would be helpful and for you to
submit to us that would be helpful also
senator gray do you have anything you
want to say um just that when you try to
do all the house members that's one
website the senate has its own website
uh the easiest way to get there is right
off the general report page then on the
right hand side about halfway or more
down
there's a link both to the house's
website and in the senate's website
so i just want to make that clear if you
do want to send to both committees you
would need to go to
both of the email addresses that are
listed on the page
so with that is there anybody else who'd
like to see here
senator
[Music]
i'm just i think it's the 25th a week
from this coming monday
i've scheduled a meeting it's only a
15-minute meeting
because there won't be a lot to discuss
but we will
you know at that meeting we'll make some
decisions uh as a chair you know there's
a i can schedule meetings but i can't do
a whole lot so uh you know you will get
an opportunity
you know and the rest of the committee
to
express your opinions
on the house side i think you might have
heard there's the date of november 18th
those of you who are here from the house
now maybe
calendar days that we follow and we will
be meeting the november 18th deadline
because that doesn't end the legislative
process is well known
that goes into next year
um so we will be done with that part of
our work by november 18th which is why
we wanted to get out here so we can
start looking at things and
the final schedules have not been
figured out but again if you go to that
website as soon as meetings are
scheduled you will see them on that
website and you'll be able to
know what we're doing as soon as
friendly committee members know what
they're doing and i have figured out
what we're doing um because that's
exactly what happens when something gets
said it goes to the staff who puts it
out on the calendar and on the website
so you'll be able to watch
but november 18
and with that i want to thank you all
very much for coming tonight and and
having us here at this beautiful
facility
it's been a pleasure to be up here and
um